european ministers responsible for
energy policy meet in luxembourg on
friday june 7 to sign off on an approach
for completing the eu's internal energy
market by 2014.
the aim is to ensure that no member
state is left off europe's gas and
electricity grids after 2015 and to
improve the rights of consumers
global warming and recent energy supply
disputes have raised the awareness in
europe of a need to have sustainable
secure and competitive energy sources
the internal energy market plan whose
implementation will be reviewed at the
end of next year will help the eu shift
to a low carbon economy and make it less
reliant on unstable energy providers
abroad
the ministers will place emphasis on
energy savings through smart appliances
and the need to educate consumers so
they can make informed choices
they will also underline people's rights
to affordable energy stressing the need
for transparency equality and
predictability when it comes to
electricity or gas contracts billing and
price schemes